Another important distinction, is that any file you put
in the cache, has to actually be downloadable. If
I put something in here that doesn't actually exist,
and then try to update the cache again, you'll notice
that I get a resource fetch failed event. And
the problem is, this means that the cache is
not being updated. It doesn't just fail to cache
that one file. It doesn't update the cache at all.
This is to make sure that sets of
resources can be managed together. But be sure to
watch the console log and make sure that
you're getting the right things. The important poitn here
is that the app cached contents are used
immediately, even when you're online. The design of Appcash
is offline first. The user gets content immediatly, rather
than having to wait for the network to respond.